ich würde ich glaube damit anfangen dass
wir dass das was mir jetzt seit langem
am Herzen liegt nämlich
das wir in Deutschland sehr häufig über
realpolitische Ansätze diskutieren und
es gibt auch einige Stimmen die davon
überzeugt sind dass man wirklich die
Ukraine
zu den Verhandlungen zwingen sollen und
ich habe das Gefühl man ist wirklich
nicht bereit neue Ansätze auszuarbeiten
und klebt sehr stark an realpolitischen
Ansätzen die nicht mehr
zeitgemäß sind und manchmal habe ich
auch das Gefühl man möchte einfach den
Status Quo aufrecht erhalten und ist
nicht bereit für sozusagen die
Beziehungen als mit zu Russland zu
ändern und versuche sie wirklich
aufrecht zu erhalten und ich habe das
Gefühl man muss wirklich offener sein
und außen politische einfach Strategie
mit Blick auf Russland überdenken und
sich wirklich Gedanken und zum Teil auch
von Russland zu verabschieden
und was ich auch
mir wünschen würde dass man ganz genau
weiß welche Zukunft man für die Ukraine
oder welche Zug und man mit der Ukraine
sieht wenn ich es einmal konkret machen
darf sie fühlen sich also sagen die
Ukraine ist vom Westen im Stich gelassen
was finden sie denn was Deutschland
konkret noch stärker tun kann wir haben
ja beispielsweise Wirtschaftssanktionen
beschlossen die unser Land hart treffen
wir befinden uns im energiekrieg also
Deutschland leidet die Wirtschaft leidet
die Bürger leiden wo würden Sie denn
sagen was Deutschland zu wenig Macht ich
würde nicht sagen dass die Ukraine jetzt
sich in Stich gelassen fühlen das würde
ich das finde ich ein bisschen
übertrieben weil eigentlich das muss man
schon auch sagen der Westen hat viel
gemacht und ohne Westen wird die Ukraine
auch den alleine nicht siegen ich glaube
es ist wichtig sich vor der Russland zu
verabschieden wir denken immer dass wenn
Putin nicht weiter an der Macht ist oder
wäre dann können wir wiederum die
Beziehungen mit Russland aufbauen und
das ist
wir glauben nicht daran dass die auch
die kollektive Verantwortung für all
dieser Kriegsverbrechen die jetzt sind
in der Ukraine stattfinden dass wir
diese Verbrechen auch die Gesellschaft
die Verantwortung tragen soll und wir
sprechen in der Öffentlichkeit in der
öffentlichen Debatten weniger darüber
wie wir eigentlich das butische Regime
zu Verantwortung ziehen können sozusagen
wir und das finde ich immer spannend
dass man vergisst überall diese
Kriegsverbrechen man möchte wiederum die
Beziehungen auf ja so wie immer hatten
haben aber und ist bereit eigentlich
auch die Kriegsverbrechen die Augen zu
tun aber wir haben uns ja eigentlich von
Russland verabschiedet wo haben wir das
noch nicht getan in der politischen
Debatten habe ich nicht das Gefühl dass
wir uns davon verabschiedet haben haben
Sie ein konkretes Beispiel ich glaube
das ist eher so all diese öffentliche
Diskussion die wir haben
und das ist eine gute Frage auch an die
Politik ich habe das Gefühl wir sind im
Modus des Abwartens was passiert danach
und es gibt auch so kleine Zeichen wenn
man zum Beispiel sagt immer ja das ist
der putinische Krieg aber nicht der
russische Krieg oder wir sprechen von
Ukraine Krieg aber nicht vom sozusagen
russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine das
alles hat Konsequenzen und ich muss
sagen das ist wir werden auch das Sehen
nach dem Winter nach all diese Inflation
ob auch die und deutsche Gesellschaft
bereit wäre weiterhin diesen Preis zu
zahlen und die Politik ist schon gefragt
auch stärker zu kommunizieren womit wir
zu tun haben die die deutsche Politik
das muss man ehrlich sagen ist vor allem
auch dafür gewählt Schaden vom deutschen
Volk abzuwenden da ist natürlich dann
auch die Frage die man stellen muss ist
die Politik da nicht auch irgendwann
auch Anwalt der deutschen Bürger ich
verstehe Anliegen sehr gut aber die
Frage die ich da noch gerne an Sie
stellen würde ist die Politik ob sie das
nachvollziehen kann die Politik muss
natürlich abwägen Zuwendung für die
Ukraine und deutsche Bürger ja so so
sehe ich sehe ich das auch aber
damit womit wir heute konfrontiert sind
das ist nicht nur der Ukraine Krieg und
damit ist nicht nur die Ukraine
konfrontiert sondern wir als Westen und
wenn wir das Trennen werden und sagen
dass eigentlich trifft uns nicht dann
haben sie recht aber das trifft uns alle
aber wenn wir so umgegangen wären oder
wenn man mit uns so umgegangen wäre nach
dem dritten Reich so nach dem Motto mit
denen das sind die paarias mit denen
werden wir nie wieder was zu tun haben
wollen sie müssen doch zumindest die
Chance geben dass das Russland sich auch
sozusagen entwickeln kann dass man mit
dem jetzigen Regime kann ich viel
Verständnisse finden aber ich finde sie
können auch nicht sagen der Russe an
sich ist schlecht oder so das kann auch
nicht gesagt aber deutschland hat
im Augenblick ist da alles sind sind
diplomatische
Finanzierung nicht angesagt aber es muss
doch unsere Hoffnung sein dass wir auch
mit solchen Völkern in Zukunft wieder
friedlich zusammenarbeiten die Ukraine
auch nicht eigentlich weil eigentlich
die Ukraine ist das Land das war so an
Russland grenzt und die Ukraine möchte
auch konstruktive Beziehungen haben aber
es geht jetzt darum aber wir behandeln
nicht richtig die Frage ist worüber
können wir behandeln und ich sehe auch
gar keine Möglichkeit das Russland jetzt
behandeln will ganz ehrlich
immer gibt es da gab es aber danach
erfolgte Butcher und danach erfolgte
auch viele andere schreckliche
Geschichten und ich glaube da kann man
nicht einfach sagen wir machen die Augen
zu und es ist uns egal dass die Menschen
hier massakriert wurden kommen wir noch
einmal auf das Verhältnis zu Schaden von
deutschen Volk abzuwenden und die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine weil da
haben sie auch richtig eingeworfen Frau
Merkel muss man eigentlich auch mal die
Politik fragen wie gehen Sie damit um
weil es ist ja schon Spannungsfeld nö so
Putin greift die Ukraine an aber er
meint uns
er meint unsere Freiheit er meint unsere
Demokratie unseren Stil zu leben das was
andere Völker attraktiv finden wo die
auch hin wollen und wo die mitmachen
wollen er meint die EU er meint
vielleicht auch die NATO aber ich sehe
überhaupt keinen Gegensatz und wenn er
uns auch meint wie weit würden Sie also
gehen
ja ich bin durchaus der Meinung dass wir
schwere Waffen in die Ukraine liefern
können das verkürzt das Leid und den
Krieg ich bin da der Auffassung wie die
Vorsitzende des Verteidigungsausschusses
aber ich muss auch sagen dass ich
Respekt habe vor den Entscheidungen die
der Bundeskanzler fällt und trifft weil
ihm auch immer mehr Informationen
vorliegen als mir als Abgeordneten ich
möchte einen anderen Aspekt da
reinbringen im Moment gibt es keine
Grundlage für eine militäre für eine für
ein Regimewechsel in Moskau es brauchte
militärische Niederlage die kann kommen
es braucht aber auch eine
wirtschaftliche Niederlage es braucht
auch Druck
bestenfalls von den Oligarchen und der
Militär ich glaube am Ende wird es nur
oligaretten
ich lasse mich nicht erpressen okay also
auch wenn selbst bist du Atomwaffen geht
Atomwaffen
und strategische Waffen und die
taktischen Waffen ich gehe davon aus
dass das passieren kann dass sie
eingesetzt werden die haben aber nur
einen